the thing I will be talking about today
is enjoy it worked with that was [ __ ]
unplug from the University of Warsaw
okay so the the thing is maybe a little
bit off topic for this conference
conference however it has definitely
some functional inequality inequalities
flavor maybe there is less about the
discrete spaces but these will also come
up by the end of the talk at some moment
okay so let's begin with something
really classical namely the Gaussian
concentration so in one of its
formulations not in the strongest one it
says that if you have a function on RN
real valued function which is Lipschitz
with respect to the euclidean Euclidean
norm in in RN and you have a gaussian
standard random vector in that space on
the rent then you know how we function f
deviates from its mean like you know you
know what are the what are the tails you
have a upper bound for the tails it's
just says that that details decays
exponentially fast roughly like like the
tail of the one dimensional Gaussian
distribution here properly normalized
namely with the variance l squared well
let's take some some toy examples the
first one is really actually actually
the trigger one namely the the linear
functional here everything is really
simple let's take this linear functional
of a normal one then
well actually we know the distribution
of of this function under our Gaussian
vector exactly namely this is standard
one-dimensional standard Gaussian so we
will also know
we'll also know the tales these are just
just Gaussian and let's take something a
little bit less trivial still simple
namely function on RN given as Euclidean
length of the of some linear
transformation of the vector X is some
some matrix and this is ellipses
function with the Lipschitz constant
which is just the operator norm of of a
operator as so with respect to the eoq
Lydian Euclidean metric on RN okay so
here well as a few words about about the
proofs of Gaussian concentrations from
okay so it actually takes its roots from
a Gaussian is a parametric inequality
which is like much stronger statement
however the prove it's it's more much
more involved so people where we're
looking for for some simpler approaches
to two if one just want to obtain the
the Gaussian concentration so well this
this list is by no means complete but
let me just mention
the nice and simple proof of marae using
stochastic calculus and Ito formula for
Brownian motion and also the functional
inequalities approach our approach by
with a semigroup methods which is due to
gross Herbst and and many other people
like of legend well this list of names
is also known by no means complete
ok ok ok so let's stick to the to this
last approach well so we'll need a
notion of entropy of of non-negative
random variable and let us recall the
what we mean by logarithmic Sobolev
inequality will will say that random
vector in RN satisfies the logarithmic
stability in equality with some constant
L if the following functional inequality
is is satisfied for all smooth functions
F defined on RN so well what are the
classical well-known facts now
well-known facts about about these
inequalities namely well the standard
Gaussian measure in RN satisfies this
inequality with constant 1 well this is
somehow the reason for for this factor
to here and also well do 2 by argument
due to helps to we know that if a random
vector X satisfies the logarithmic so
belief in equality it also satisfies the
Gaussian concentration namely if we have
a 1 Lipschitz say 1 Lipschitz function
on RN then the
the concentrate the concentration in
this sense is satisfied well what the
the way that the Herbst argument roughly
roughly goes is you want to apply
logarithmic Sobolev inequalities for
inequality for this family of functions
which gives you some differential
equality and then some groom world type
lemma gives you some estimate for a
Laplace transform of of a function f
which by chebyshev's inequality turns
there's two to this tail inequality okay
but we will take somewhat a different
route instead of deriving the
concentration directly from from Logan
so bleep inequality let's let's see what
it does the logarithmic symbolic
inequality implies so well this is the
argument that first appeared explicitly
I guess in the paper of Fighters true
and Stroke in 94 which says that
whenever the vector X in RN satisfies
the logarithmic Sobolev inequality it
satisfies the the following sub life
type inequality let's say nemily
here for also arbitrary smooth function
f the growth of the Pima piece l PL v
norm of F minus its mean is controlled
by a LP norm of the land Euclidean
length of the gradients of of F no
no no no no no but it's not not
equivalent logarithmic symbolic
inequalities is stronger well actually
in in the context of Gaussian measure
gaussian random vectors in RN this
inequality was actually known for some
time already it appeared in the in the
work of PCF from 1886 and it has a
pretty short elegant proof and also very
very elementary you can it's like a hot
page so well from in what follows we
will we will use the following
equivalent form of of this inequality
star namely let us introduce the the
standard Gaussian vector G in in RN
which is independent of our main random
vector X and rewrite the right-hand side
of our inequality in the following in
the following fashion well if we look at
this expression conditionally on X
namely if we fix X this is just linear
forming in G so well we know for a fixed
X we know where what what the
distribution it has it's just one
dimensional normal with with the
variance which is square root of the
length of the of the gradient of F at at
a fixed X well so we know the growth the
the growth of the of the alpi norms this
is roughly square root of P as for
gaussians times the length of x the
square of the variance which is here the
length
Euclidean length of the of the gradient
so
sy this recast to this right-hand side
we just need to drop the square root of
P and up to the constant it's up to some
universal constant it's the same well so
so this inequality or in this
formulation is well says something about
how we control the LP norms of EF minus
its mean so how it relates to to the
tails may be let us let us explain it
briefly well so on the one side it is
just the chebyshev inequality if you
have a let's say or some non-negative
random variable real valued now let's
think that why it's just the absolute
value of f minus its mean so then the
chebyshev's inequality gives you the
following estimate for the for the tail
so now if you know the the if you had
some good upper bound for for the LP
norm of of random variable Y you you
have you have a nice tails tail estimate
for by well so if you know that the rate
of growth of the of the moments of y is
x square root of P not faster than
square root of P you know that your the
tails of why are sub Gaussian and if the
growth is sub linear then you know that
your your random variable is
sub-exponential okay and in the other
way around well maybe not the other way
around but but but the other the other
bound Emily here we from the upper bound
for the for the for the moments we have
the upper bound for the for the tails
and the reversed inequality we can we
can we can get by a so-called policy
mona inequality name and you have a
lower bounds for the moments and you
know some
something about the regularity of the
growth of the of the moments then then
you have a lower bound for the for the
tails they may leave
well now let's think that the
non-negative random variable is our Y to
the power P so eventually f - its mean
absolute value to the power P then well
the the political inequality in its
in its abstract form that says says says
this so this here here you will if Z is
y to the power P this is a ratio between
the LP norm of Y and norm of the order
to P so if you know if you know that
this ratio is not too small namely you
have you know that the the moments
behaves somewhat regulary do not cannot
grow rapidly if you have twice as big
moment it doesn't does not it doesn't
grow suddenly then then you will you
have the following lower bound for the
for the tail so now to to make it make
the sense out of it you know you have to
know the some some some good lower bound
for the LP norm of Y ok so let's see
some some examples which goes beyond the
Lipschitz let'slet's we'll all these
still is some classical namely let's
take the quadratic form in in a Gaussian
vector which we can represent this way
as where a sum let's see symmetric n
times and matrix with let's take the
zero sum diagonal to make the zero mean
well if you so well
you can diagonalize a name we find the
ortho ortho column matrix q which
changed the basis so that in the new
basis the matrix a is diagonal let's say
it has terms di on the diagonal form in
the diagonal matrix D where Anton and
the other ingredient is the fact that
Gaussian distribution is invariant under
rotation so if you apply the
from of our orthogonal transformation to
Jesus the distribution stays the same so
so actually this random variable and
this one is the same as the same
distribution well but this now is just a
sum of random variables G I squared with
with some coefficients di well some of
the ice is zero because we had zeros on
diagonals of the trace state is zero we
can subtract once to make it
well now the sum of independent random
variables which are which are centered
and well using some some classical to
classical tools from from probability
like bursting equalities for sums of
independent subjects potential random
variables you get the you get the tail
of of your random variable namely the
tail is well is within some range the
tail is sub Gaussian and for larger T
the further talese is sub-exponential
and the quantities that comes into the
game are well the Euclidean length of
the of the vector D of D is which well
it's the same as the hilbert smith norm
of the of the initial matrix a namely
the square root square root of the sum
of the squares of the entries of matrix
a and the other quantity is is just the
operator norm of a well in terms of
moments this this just says that the
growth of the of the LP norm of this
random variable is controlled from above
by the square root of P times the the
Gilberts mid norm as P times the
operator on the by the way the the first
one is men
always larger than than than the second
norm and it can be can be essentially
larger or especially in a large
dimension actually well for this example
of of the quadratic form this this
inequality for moments or for details
can be reversed up to the constants so
so this so this upper estimate is seen a
sense in a sense tight can be can be can
be up to the constants can be can be
reversed
okay so let's well this was about the
quadratic forms let's now take something
even more complicated
I mean well now we have we have a matrix
a which is actually multi indexed matrix
we have a D indices think of well
previously D was true now you can think
about D to be three for example and
let's assume that this bootie index
matrix is symmetric in a sense that it's
invariant under the permutation of
indices and has zeros on all diagonals
meaning that if two indices are the same
then the the corresponding entry is zero
well then let's take the following
function in a Gaussian random vector
well you can here think about a as a
multi linear operator and you just apply
the same vector G D times well which
which is just just this this sum over
all the indices ranging from 1 to say n
this kind of object is is known in the
literature as Gaussian chaos actually
the tetrahedra of Gaussian cares because
all the due to the assumption that we
have zeros on all the diagonals there
are no
see here which is in in in power greater
than one so you cannot have squares or
cubes or whatever okay and this is a
result due to rock a lotta hoie which
says which provides the two sided
estimates for the moments and tails of
such a tetrahedral Gaussian cases okay
so so as we previously saw on the
previous slide for D equal to 2 it is
somewhat simple because we can economize
things that the Gaussian distribution is
invariant under under rotations and here
the things for already for D equal to 3
the things get much more complicated
well so what what are the estimates
though ok so there is a precise formula
I mean up to the unit up to some
universal constant this is the same
quantity from the from the above and
from the below controls the the LP
moments of such a Gaussian chaos and the
rate of growth of the moment is is is
the following there is some ok the
growth of the speed square root of P
linear in P and P to the 3 3 health well
and these norms the first norm is about
like a hilbert smith norm for this 3
linear operator the last one is like the
the norm of of the multilinear of a seen
as a multi linear operator on L to n
times or to n times to N and this is
some somewhat a mixture of these yeah
so if you apply the coupling you well
you end up with applying the independent
copies of the same vector to so this is
like a multi linear version of the same
question and well actually it was the
same question now and for D equal to
three it's it's it's it's tough right
actually what Rocco did was well to to
first apply the coupling and then to
answer the decoupled version - and this
is no no no no for D equal to three
because it wasn't right because yes so
if you have the estimate from below
which up to the constant much is the one
from above then and and also the more
the moments growth regularly namely the
twice as big moment is not much bigger
than so then the poly sigmund gives you
the tale estimate from below which also
matches the detail the upper tail
estimate from Joe Bishop right so this
is this
yeah the supplier you can you can you
translate this problem to decoupled one
when you just you have just multilinear
yeah you you definitely prefer working
with decoupled the question namely you
have having the the multi linear forming
an independent copies of Gauss and
Merton vector right having like G G 1
capital G 1 to capital g tu right and
then then you then you think what what
what to do in still the decoupled
question in in D equal to 2 is it's easy
there are many ways you can do it for
similar reasons like you like for the
quadratic forms this is like very
similar thing but but still for D equal
to 3 or higher it's it stopped well so
here it's it's natural natural
assumption well if it is not symmetric
then but it's all 0 some diagonal its
you can still make it symmetric right
and and it doesn't change the function
you just take the average over all
permutations it doesn't change anything
and in the decoupled version of the
question the the assumption neither of
CIMMYT symmetricity or having 0 some
diagonal is not needed anymore
it's it's not the relevant
okay so so well like the Gaussian
concentration we saw that well the
linear functionals have a normal
distribution linear functionals in
indels and vector are just one
dimensional Gaussian and the thing is
easy and Gaussian concentration allows
you to pass to the lips its function but
but which are not not linear anymore
so in the same spirit we want to drop
well motivated by it by these previous
examples like gaussian chaos or
quadratic forms or d linear forms in
gaussian random vectors we wanted to
pass to something something nonlinear
and this is what our result is more or
less about so let's well the main
assumption is is this some Olaf type
inequality here you can you can think so
random vector X satisfies this
inequality this is what we assume well
you can think that the axis is standard
Gaussian in RN okay so what what the
result says is the following if you have
a well in in the case of order like to
so we are going from from quadratic
forms to something not which is not
quadratic or not building building here
so let's take the function f which is c2
such that we have a following point wise
estimates for second order derivatives
namely we know how to globally estimate
the hilbert smith normal the second
order derivative then the same about the
operator norm by some some two
quantities a HS and h o p and then we
have the following following
inequalities for the rate of growth of
moments and for the tails of function f
minus its mean well and if we look at
and estimate for the 40 moments if f is
the quadratic form as as previously
then well this terms canceled out and
and what you what you end up with is the
same as as previously namely you have
the growth of the order square root of p
x times the Hilbert Schmidt norm plus
linear growth in P with the coefficient
which is operator norm of the matrix
that that is associated with the
quadratic form here in the more general
setting what you want you additionally
have is is this term which is well you
take you look for the gradient of your
function on your space and you take the
average of this gradient as a as a
vector and then you take the Euclidean
length of of this average and this is
the coefficient that comes that pops up
with well with the rate of growth square
root of square root of P and well
translating to two moments estimated it
gives you the following tailing equality
so you have you know that that your
function is sub Gaussian within some
range and and for larger T's its
sub-exponential okay so let me outline
the proof because actually this is a
simple trick so well so this is our main
assumption this function in the quality
of the Sobel f-type which is as we
explained no it's known that it's
implied for example by a logarithmic
symbolic inequality so definitely
satisfied by by Gaussian random vector
well so we we want to look at it at in
in this equivalent form where we drop
the square root of P but instead we take
a scalar product with of the gradient of
of our function with the independent
standard random vector a Gaussian random
vector X can be whatever satisfies this
inequality but body is an independent
standard Gaussian
in our end well so then we apply this
inequality to to our function f for
which we want to have this moment
estimate well and plus some tract plus a
triangle inequality for LP norm namely
what what we do here in in comparison to
this right hand side we just subtract
and add this this function the scalar
product and take its LP norm well so
then we can translate it back get rid of
this Gaussian vector and the square root
of P pop up pops up and well here what
what happened is I just for some
convenience I I renamed the G to G bar
it's still independent Gaussian
independent from X and well what what
happened else I we've pulled out this
expectation outside the scalar product
so now we have to integrate with respect
to X only right okay so now what what we
do we deal with this with this first
term that we have and conditionally on G
bar we used our functional main
functional inequality main assumption
once again well we use it to function H
given us a scalar product of grad of F
scalar product with with G bar z bar is
some fixed vector writing we do it
conditionally on G bar well and what
what we get is well this term we just
write rewrite and and and what we get is
well actually the right-hand side of of
this inequality involves well we have to
take a gradient of H and what will
happen if we take the gradient of H we
will end up with the second order
derivative of of f2 which we will apply
again independent copy of
of the Gauss standard Gaussian which
which is G again right so what what is
here conditionally on on X is nothing
but so if you fix X it's nothing but by
the be linear forming in two independent
standard Gaussian so well we know what
it is
it's LP LP norm right well previously we
did it for for quadratic forms but for
billionaire forms it's it's the same
it's controlled by P times the operator
norm and square root of P times times
the cube R Schmidt norm well so finally
if we have some global estimates for for
this operator norm and he must be norm
of the second order derivative then then
we are done we can actually replace this
LP norm with Alvin infinity norm if we
have this additional information and
well actually that's that that's the
trick well what happens if you if you go
into the higher order well you can you
can we can we have the same result now
your function is G times differentiable
and well actually what you do you do
this trick D times you iterate this main
assumptions Sobolev inequality G fives
or D minus one and well and you will end
up with tagil estimates or the or the
moment estimates that involves well
again the mean of the of the gradient
then the mean of the signature or the
derivative and so on and so on
actually well so this will be some some
deterministic quantities of which you
will take well here it's it's just a
vector so you as previously you will
take just the Euclidean length here this
will be some deterministic matrix which
you will take the operator norm and
hibbert Schmidt norm as the quantities
involved in the estimates
for D equal to three there will be there
will be this also with this intermediate
norm as in La Follette hours result and
in higher order will this norms at least
the notation gets more complicated and
and by the end of the day you you when
you reach the the last degree of
differentiability you well what you
usually want to want to know is like
some point wise estimate for such norms
of of of the last derivative of the
highest order derivative of opium well
so like in Lipschitz setting you have
you just differentiate once and you want
to know that the point the the point
wise estimate for for the derivative
namely being one Lipschitz is like
knowing that your gradient everywhere
does not in the length does not exceed
one here you you can drop drop it in for
the price of knowing something about how
the the gradient the the and the higher
derivative sitting in the mean and
knowing some some eventually some point
was estimated for the higher highest
order derivative okay so here what what
would pop up what you will what you will
encounter is is the problem of
estimating the moments of multi linear
forms in in in independent Gaussian
random vectors as seen in the previous
argument we had just the billionaire
form which is somebody well so this this
result is seen a sense optimal for the
class of if you take the the polynomials
as the class of the function sent and
and X to be a Gaussian standard Gaussian
random vector this this result turns out
to be to be optimal well so let us let
me mention one
while application to the random matrices
let's consider the a to be a big nur n
times and vigor matrix well which
entries satisfy law remixable life in
equality you can think that the entries
are Gaussian standard Gaussian for
example one dimensional and and zero one
let's lambda 1 up to lambda and B eigen
values and let's take some function on
the real line a smooth function and
consider such a random variable Z such
as sound which is in the theory is
called the Linea eigen value statistic
and the result of Brianna Danza to me
says that well if the function f is
Lipschitz namely have infinity L
infinity norm of F prime is is bounded
then you know that that your random
variable is sub Gaussian well what our
result implies is the following the
following tail estimate in which well it
resembles maybe a very stein type
inequality somehow namely you have a sub
Gaussian regime and sub-exponential 1
but here you do not have to do to
estimate that a to to to assume that
function f is Lipschitz
why well here you have some milder norm
involving the first order derivative of
F namely the integral of F prime squared
with respect to the semicircle law well
there is some some error term coming
from to-to-to-to issues actually and
well there is some exponential decay
well in in both these terms
well the price you pay for
or going beyond the beyond the Lipchitz
test functions f is that you have to
assume that second-order derivative is
bounded however for large n when the
dimension of the matrix grows this well
at least for fixed function this this
term becomes negligible and and also
deserve the same about the several time
maybe let me pass to the to the second
part of the talk well so somewhat
inspired with with with the result that
you've already presented let us think
what what can happen for more general
distributions well more general in in in
at least in one way Emily well this
assumption at least like our random
vector satisfies logarithmic symbolic
inequality is quite quite restrictive in
a format it was presented with with
continuous gradient it's it rules out
the discrete distributions for example
well so so let's see what happens if you
have random vectors whose coefficients
are independent which well is somewhat
restricted by quite quite common case
and sub Gaussian well what we mean by
the random
this why now is just one dimensional
random variable and we say that it's sub
Gaussian with with the coefficient given
by this number if this infinite moon
infimum is is finite okay so so in this
setting we as i've said we take the
random vector x with independent sub
Gaussian random variables and let's
assume that all all the sub curves and
coefficients of all our coordinates are
bounded by some some some some common
constant l well now for for the
beginning let's let's stick to the case
of of degree two namely here will not
have arbitrary functions as previously
well but just multivariate polynomials
and let's begin with the multivariate
polynomial of degree 2 and well what you
can what you can get is the following
estimate which is
exactly matches the one we had
previously for general function f twice
differentiable with some with some point
wise estimates for the for the norms of
the last order derivative is order
derivative and but here now well we we
relaxed some of the assumption for the
for the underlying distribution for the
price of the smaller class of the
functions namely polynomials only well
if you allow if you want higher degree
polynomials then the estimates will
involve norms of the higher order
derivative of the off of your polynomial
the same norms are like like we
encountered previously
okay so let's maybe write down more
precisely the the result for degree
three we have a degree three polynomial
and then we have the following estimate
for for the moments and well here again
as previous is like expected we take it
expected gradient and it's led expected
second-order derivative and it's Hilbert
Schmidt and operator nor for the third
order derivative since this is a
polynomial of degree three this is
already already some some deterministic
quantities deterministic three linear
form and there is no
and it's you can drop X or whatever this
is just the deterministic quantity okay
and here let me maybe outline quickly
the the proof or at least the titre
Hedra case namely the case when your
polynomial of degree here of degree
capital d which can be you can be
general like two three or whatever three
was on the previous slide in the in the
formulation of the result tetrahedra
which means that all the all the
coordinates of our random vector X
appears in the power at most at most one
okay so this case is somewhat simpler
than the under general and that gives
some idea at least partially what what
the tools we use and here some some
additional tricks in this simple
tetrahedral case works that do not want
to work in the in the general case so
well what what you can what you can do
you can write your multivariate
polynomials just just using the just
using the Taylor expansion this is a
finite expansion of course and well
since our function is the tetrahedral
polynomial then the expectation commutes
will do it with this function because
well these are two two things
the polynomial is tetrahedral this is
one thing and the other is that that
that the coordinates are independent and
well the same about the derivatives
because the robotics are again
polynomials well so so what you what you
have here is just here you have some
multivariate polynomials you apply it to
the copies of I mean to do the same to
the you apply the same random random
vector d times well so this is some
teacher hydral chaos in octahedral
multivariate polynomial in in this
random vector so what you do you use
decoupling inequalities to have it to
have it decoupled this is one thing and
the other is symmetrization which also
helps so what the cutting inequality and
somatization technique does for you is
that the LP norms of of these guys are
comparable with their P norms of these
so you just translate your your question
into somewhat simpler because then
knowing that your here X sub 1 X sub T
are independent copies of the same of
the same of the initial random vector
capital X and and now knowing that the
coordinates are sub Gaussian you can
somewhat easily compare
compared the norms of of these with the
norms of of these where you have you
apply instead of applying the sub
Gaussian random vectors to to to this
multi multivariate polynomial you you
just apply the the gaussians what pops
up here is is this constant altitude to
the little D was was side two
coefficients measuring how how sub
Gaussian random vector is okay so you
you end up with with the problem of
estimating the moments of the of the of
the Gaussian chaos which is which is the
result of over tau well so actually this
is like one dimensional think once you
have we decoupled you it's it doesn't
matter whether it's out there D or one
because it goes by induction and for
order one this is like you here you will
have the sum of independent well here is
important that X has independent
coordinates right so so this will be a
linear form in symmetric independent
random variables and you can just
dominate the LP norm of these will be
norm of of the same linear form in
Gaussian this is it's not difficult
because the end it seems just statement
about the order one actually because
then because you are in the decouple
setting it's it's those by touch
what if you condition going to the very
first line what if you couldn't use
conditioner not the first line in this
month okay organize your son do some
over isube - one of the new condition
instead of using the coupling for some
reason it doesn't want to work that way
that is directly right so well you
arrange the things in the way you want
to condition but but then I think it
becomes messy and you lose this III
think if it does it will not work so
well so and well it's it's somewhat more
it's better to use the coupling at the
start I guess
but if you do it twice you will have to
estimate some operator norm of some
matrix with correlated entries which is
which is quite difficult okay so so just
to finish let me let me let me show
briefly application of of this
inequalities for polynomials in in sub
Gaussian random variables so here the
sub graphs and random variables will be
a binary u 0 1 random variables biased 1
namely taking value 1 with probability P
and 0 with pre 50 1 minus P so well so
this will be about the problem of
counting copies of a fixed graph H in in
GNP so let's name Y sub H the random
variables that counts this copy it comes
the number of these copies and well in
this field there is a question about
about the deviation of such a random
variable above above its mean well and
it turns out that well actually this
problem is about having the polynomial
of degree of the number of edges in the
in the graph H of copies which one we
want to count in polynomial of such a
degree in Vario in in binary random
random variables multivariate
polynomials binary random variables and
well these variables x i's are
independent so we have the vector x
consisted of these independent
coordinates and each coordinate is sub
gaussian with this sub gaussian
coefficient piece probably
of this random variable X I bind a
random variable X I to to attain value 1
okay and well it's there is a pretty
general result you to dance another
scription routine ski that gives the
upper and lower estimate for for this
probability but well almost the the
upper meets the the lower bound well
almost
because up to the this logarithmic term
in in 1 over P well so recently DiMarco
and Chatterjee and DeMarco in town is
somewhat independently last year they
came up with with a sharp lower bound
sharp meaning the this upper bound for
the tail meets known lower bound duty on
superscription routine ski for the case
of the of the triangles or or cliques
and actually what our general result for
for polynomials in in sub calcium
independence of Gaussian random
variables can get is that well in some
range of parameters namely namely when P
is sufficiently large then we we have
the the the sharp estimate for the for
the upper tail in the case when we count
the number of copies of the CK which is
the cycle of Overland K well so what's
what this this application of our result
to this problem involves is like you
have to estimate these all the norms of
of of these quantities this actually
these are deterministic but you have to
estimate all these all these norms like
Hilbert Schmidt and operator and all
these mixtures and well this this
actually can be carried out so even
these norms at the first glance might
look horrible in some specific
situations like this one you can you can
you can really compute something but
what what we what we get does make sense
only only four clicks even these things
you can have you can compute for any any
fixed small graph H okay so okay so okay
no no this for the general function
which is just well you assume some some
balance on the on the highest order
derivative there is no hope that you can
reverse it having controlling only the
the the the north of the derivatives
right this is like in a Gaussian
concentration in worksheets for
Lipschitz functions right you can kind
of reverse it while controlling only the
Lipschitz also this well so so we are we
are not trying to go this way yes yes so
this is not yeah this is even not trying
to go this way well okay so in this
discrete setting at us was as I was
mentioning in the second part well this
is not directly comparable I mean they
also get similar quantities that measure
the size of the function like we had
here like this expected expectation of
the derivatives but we have all bunch of
norms for them their their quantities
are somewhat simpler which makes the
probably the
you do not need too many too much effort
to apply it in the inner part in the
specific case but well for example in
this in this but also their their
inequalities are there are some
parameters that you can place some other
parameters this is like a whole family
of inequalities for in our case there is
a concrete I mean the the single
formulation I mean you have a function
or a polynomial ends and some calcium
independent variables and you have an
equality for them there is some
arbitrary can place but for example this
problem of counting cycles you do not
you do not get the optimum result ours
in our and from our inequality which
which turns out to be 2 2 2 2 2 we are
being able to get the optimal result of
this in some range of parameter so
please grab GNP so but from there you
you things you cannot you cannot get it
so
this will damage motivating
for instance because when you bought
some some kinds
so in the setting of graffman to support
hunting is
anything there your technique I don't
know this is this has some some other
labor actually this is not about yeah
but the result is not like focusing on
Taylor moment estimates right this is
more or softs well here we have like
some some hard inequalities that
this is like larger deviation right
it was
because the pulse would be
their conjecture for the pouch-like type
inequality for yes so well so what what
we got here is some something not very
satisfactory as the coefficient
controlling the the Gaussian part is not
true variance of or if there was this
the sub life type norm of F prime I mean
the integral of f prime square with
respect to the the semicircle low and
this is not even in asymptotic sense
this is not not a true limiting variance
for for din your eigen value statistics
so this is not the right quantity that
we can this is somewhat Welles may be
actually the the limiting variance that
is that is known due to the central
limit theorem for for a protein iranian
value statistics this is quite a
complicated expression and what we had
with some some other examples it but but
it's not exactly exactly distant but we
do not know what should be what should
be there exactly if we can if we want to
have a burst I type in equality for for
a fixed dimension we still don't know
what what should be there but we we
actually do not do not hope that this
kind of simple approach can can tackle
this problem
I think one should one should when she
did something worse Martin